good morning John it is that magical
time of year between the time when we
give gifts and the time when we
celebrate the new year magical in that I
don't have anything I'm supposed to be
doing I know I kind of just want to go
back to work which maybe I'm a
workaholic or maybe yeah just got a
really great job yeah this is the one
time of the year when I just get to
decide for myself what I want to do so
you got sledding oh this was a bad idea
as a bush right dork the moon and
entering science questions on tumblr
also playing video games eating fried
egg sandwiches cuddling Slee answering
side questions on tumblr turns out that
it's just one of my favorite things in
the world to do and if you haven't seen
my tumblr asks here are some of the
fascinating things about the world that
I have learned due to people asking me
questions on Tom there is a kidney that
has been in three different people
person who donated it she donated it to
her brother and then he couldn't use it
it didn't work for whatever reason so
they took it out and they were like so
this is yours now you have rights over
this thing what should we can we put it
another person or should we throw it
away and he was like put it in another
brit but i think it's fascinating that'd
be like the moment it entered his body
cavity it was his and he got to decide
not his sister who was the original
owner of the kidney and not the medical
establishment who had the kidney and put
it inside of him but him the guy and he
was like yeah give it to somebody else
and they did so that kidney has been in
three different people firm wales
undergo massive changes in pressure like
if you take deep-sea fish up to not
deep-sea locations they explode if you
take fish from the top of the ocean and
bring them to the bottom then they get
crushed firm wheels they go from like
the top of the ocean all the way down to
like 2,000 feet below the ocean was the
two hundred atmospheres different
impression they're mammals so they have
lungs which are filled with air which
can cause all kinds of problems with
nitrogen getting into your plates crazy
how do they do this when they dive they
actually collapse their own lungs so
that that's not a problem and then all
the oxygen they need is stored in their
blood and their hemoglobin and in
special oxygen storage proteins in their
muscles this link of an i sounds like
it's fast and it does not take very much
time only about 300 milliseconds but on
those 300 milliseconds it only travels
one inch though it's actually very slow
like a fifth of a mile per hour slow
blinking we have created a drug which
prevents hair from going gray and
actually reverses the graying process
but it causes diarrhea and nausea and
occasionally death so that's not good
but it also is good for treating
leukemia and it cost about ninety
thousand dollars a year so hair dye you
do not know if the core of Jupiter is a
liquid or a salt it is very hot but also
under tremendous amounts of pressure in
fact if Jupiter were just ten times
bigger there would be so much pressure
that there would be sustainable fusion
reactions going on inside of it and we
would live in a binary star system
all-time favorite question though that
has been asked of me on tumblr is
highway 99 pounds on 8 1 pound of nachos
does that mean that I am 1% nacho this
question turns out to be so complicated
that I cannot answer it in this video we
may do an entire episode of scishow on
it it's fascinating
I hope you enjoyed these fascinating
science facts that I have learned I love
the world and I love weird exciting
interesting questions about the world so
thank you to people on tumblr for doing
this and yes I do know that now I'm
going to get like way more asks than I
can answer so sorry I probably won't be
able to answer your ass but I am going
on reddit right now to do an AMA if you
would like to join me you can ask me any
that is via like answering question e
today though my wrist is already
starting to hurt from the typing so not
from the video games I promised John I
hope that this week of being able to do
whatever you want is probably not
because you have kids so you're probably
doing whatever they want that sounds
like less fun but I'm sure you're
enjoying a nonetheless and I'll see you
on Tuesday today I'm here with Matthew
Gaydos and Hank green and Katherine
green and we are sliding on things down
the snow